hi I'm Olivia Palermo and my favorite
movie is Auntie Mame what i lutely love
about Auntie Mame is the time period I
mean you look at the costume design you
look at the interiors and you know I'm
constantly inspired by it and there's a
mystery about it you know there's a
there's an R in the air that we don't
have in our time so I think that for me
it's it gives me an idea of a fantasy I
love the fact that you see a woman on
screen who has an incredible presence
and incredible confidence about her
she's full of life she has lots of color
she loves style she's really stays true
to herself and you know at the end of
the day it's it's really about friends
and family and in that sense I can
really relate to that I definitely think
that the fashion tell a story the colors
the textures the sequins but the
accessories you know I'm very much about
accessories so you know looking at the
film she always has you know some
amazing statement piece of coat hat it
could be anything I also think that the
interior design goes so goes very well
hand-in-hand with the fashion as well
because you know within life you know
your are inspired by you by your home
and in decoration at least I am my
mother is an interior designer and so to
be able to play with patterns and prints
and color and it's so important to be
able to create that in your own
lifestyle in your day to day because
that tells the story of your look and
what you're trying to accomplish and I
think that that goes back to the movie
with Auntie Mame the clothes makeup and
the accessories it gives you know a feel
of that character and that woman and
know how she is and so much she's
inspired by it definitely shines through
one of the scenes that I really enjoy is
when Agnes is just coming to auntie
Mames apartment and Auntie Mame wants to
give her a wonderful makeover and Agnes
is needing a little convincing and
auntie Mames like live live live you can
be your own woman you can be a fantastic
woman
then when she came down the stairs you
could see that the confidence came
through and I think that that is so
important and that goes back to women
today and needing to feel confident and
beautiful and it can be you know you're
getting your hair done and a little bit
of makeup it goes a long way and life is
too short so you should try new things
and you always leave the door slightly
open because you never know where where
it might lead to hi I'm Olivia Palermo
and I love Moo